et on poursuit avec Charles Philippe
David fondateur de la chair à Old
d'endurance bonsoir Jean-Philippe
bonsoir Céline alors ça fait des années
qu'on suit ça mais ce qui se passe en ce
moment c'est du jamais vu votre réaction
ma première réaction c'est dire ouf là
vraiment on va être occupé ça fait
depuis le mois de décembre qu'on voit
venir le résultat de cette enquête le
résultat sans doute de cette mise en
accusation et finalement on y est je
suis pas vraiment surpris que finalement
le jury avec le procureur brag et non
soit enfin annonce cette mise en
accusation maintenant c'est de savoir
quel va être la suite des choses parce
que en effet Azeb avait raison de dire
pour que le jury dépose cette mise en
accusation il faut certainement d'abord
qui est plus que mon avis 13 personnes
sur 24 qui était d'accord faut vraiment
une forte majorité sinon la totalité et
certainement la preuve doit être béton
d'ailleurs pour qu'on parle de plus
d'une trentaine 34 ou 35 chefs
d'accusation et on n'est pas au courant
de tous d'accusation en passant on ne
sait pas si c'est que l'affaire de
Stéphanie geford stormy Daniel qui qui
est au centre de cette mise en
accusation mais peut-être d'autres
choses d'autres accusations de fraude
par exemple donc à suivre mais ça va
être quelque chose la semaine prochaine
je vous jure en direct là de voir un
ancien président des États-Unis c'est
une première le foot c'est de le répéter
tout le temps de voir un ancien
président des Italiens
va vouloir mettre ça en spectacle ou pas
bon on dit qu'il va collaborer mais on
en sera sur lorsqu'on le verra parce que
tout est possible avec dans notre
chambre on l'a dit tellement de fois il
aurait pu refuser par exemple finalement
de quitter l'État de Floride et de et de
comparer qu'est-ce que fait alors à ce
moment-là le service secret ce qu'il le
force à prendre l'avion puis là à rendre
de synthèse ce soir qui va d'un tweet
dont il est seul capable et qui nous dit
que lui en tout cas ce qu'il concerne
l'état de Floride ne collaborera pas du
tout avec les autorités enfin les
autorités policières de Floride ne
collabor avec avec ce mandat
d'arrestation donc ça nous laisse quand
même un tout petit peu dans
l'incertitude de savoir exactement
comment cela peut-il se passer donc
suite des choses moi je suis sûr qu'on
va avoir des surprises encore et
pourtant on vient de le voir là il est
impliqué dans d'autres causes qui sont
sans doute plus graves pour la
démocratie américaine alors à quel point
c'est sérieux parce que là on parle
quand même d'une affaire de une liaison
extra-conjugale c'est de ça qu'on parle
complètement
le crime que la façon dont il a été
masqué la façon dont on tient les livres
on fait des gestes illégaux à
l'intérieur de l'organisation parce que
ça qui est arrivé dans l'organisation
Trump qui fait l'objet de cette de cette
enquête c'est le paiement on l'a dit
plusieurs fois ce soir c'est le paiement
de somme d'argent à même probablement
les fonds non seulement de
l'organisation Trump mais de la campagne
électorale de Donald Trump de 2016 c'est
ça qui est illégal parce que ça viole
beaucoup de loi électorale alors c'est
une accusation de financière plus que
l'affaire ou le dossier extra-conjugal
qui est en cause ici puis vous avez
raison de dire ce n'est que probablement
une première
moi je pense que d'autres causes qui
s'enviennent votre journaliste a
mentionné par exemple la Georgie ou là
vraiment comme vous dites là c'est une
atteinte à la démocratie et il se
prépare là aussi probablement à déposer
des chefs d'accusation peut-être
attendait-il de voir ce qui se passerait
avec Manhattan avant d'aller de l'avant
en Géorgie puis il y a toujours l'ombre
du procureur spécial Michael Scott qui
plane au-dessus de la tête dans le Trump
celui qui était nommé par le ministre de
la justice mericarlen pour faire enquête
sur le site janvier et il y a des choses
très sérieuses là qui qui vont se passer
par exemple la comparution de l'ancien
vice-président Mike Pernes ce qui va
être forcé de comparer devant ce
procureur pour expliquer lui comment il
a vu comment il a compris ce qui s'est
passé le 16 janvier est-ce qu'il a dit à
Donald Trump tout ça aussi va être en
cause donc
un sac de tout ça va être énorme pour la
vie politique américaine je pense dans
les semaines à venir mais parlons-en de
cet impact sur la course présidentielle
parce que tout ça ne le rend pas
inéligible en fait c'est ça qui est
incroyable vous pouvez effectivement
être candidat présidentiel et être en
prison c'est déjà arrivé d'air à un
candidat un jean dead je pense durant la
Première Guerre mondiale socialiste qui
était mis en prison et qui a quand même
fait campagne électorale alors mais lui
était candidat il n'a pas été déjà
président alors là dans le cas de Donald
Trump effectivement tout est permis tout
est permis il peut il peut continuer de
faire campagne électorale maintenant la
question c'est de savoir
parce que ça code de popularité monte
oui mais c'est ça le parti républiqué va
être là devant des choix absolument
cornéliens parce qu'à mon avis au moins
un quart c'est partisans 25 à 30% de ces
partisans qui eux vont être déchaînés en
faveur de Donald Trump parce que ils
achètent ce message que c'est une
persécution et non pas un procès mais le
reste des républicains évidemment il se
rallie pas tant derrière trempe que
contre le procureur spécial et contre la
démarche des démocrates visant à
politiser évidemment ces procès et faire
mal paraître dans notre mais est-ce
qu'ils ont raison de dire ça non j'en ai
pas raison de dire ça pas du tout je ne
pense pas
la justice étant scalée et puis de toute
façon aux États-Unis il y a c'est pas
que le procureur qui est un poste
électrique il y a plein de postes
sélectifs du côté démocrate que du côté
républicain mais je pense que il y a
aussi beaucoup de républicains qui vont
peut-être à la fois dire si ça nuit a
dans le champ peut-être que ça va aider
d'autres candidatures en tout cas ce
soir qui doit se positionner de manière
spéciale c'est rendre de synthèse parce
que à la fois il ne veut pas perdre les
électeurs et les électrices de Trump
mais il veut se distancer de Donald
Trump pour être mieux que lui pour se
présenter en 2024 peut-être mais pour
l'instant Trump le devant dans les
sondages alors on verra comment ça va
jouer pour ou contre nuire ou aider dans
ce qui se passe là mais il est clair que
là la démocratie américaine encore une
fois comme après le 16 janvier 2021 va
être un petit peu mise à mal ou en tout
cas tester sérieusement testé par ce
procès annoncé de de dans le Trump la
suivre on se reparle mardi certainement
merci